kind of um two halves of the same coin
it's sort of the hardware and the
software side of
what can a user and in their particular
account
what can they do okay so here we go
let's have a think about this
um
so i'm thinking about assigning rights
okay let's think about peripherals first
peripherals
um i don't know what you think of when
you hear the word peripherals maybe the
first place you heard about this word
is um when you went with technology but
for me
i think i used to get taught a lot by my
mom when i was younger and i was
learning across the street and that kind
of thing
she yelled at me and she said you got no
peripheral
vision watch out ah you know so she
would say
what does that mean by the way that i
can't see very much towards the sides
okay and actually that's true
when you're younger um your vision is
just more focused towards the center i'm
not sure why that is
um because little kids it seems would
really benefit from peripheral vision
but anyway
so peripheral as opposed to what would
be the opposite adjective to peripheral
not off at the sides i guess you'd say
it's
straightforward forward or central maybe
and i think probably this is a good
choice because another place that you
see
this word used is in the body and
describing
its nervous systems anyone remember this
from like
i don't know year 89 biology okay you've
got the
central nervous system which is made up
of does anyone know
it's it's
okay more specifically
the nerves in the spine right so that's
your central nervous system
and then you've got your peripheral
nervous system which is all of your
sensations and that kind of thing your
arms and legs etc etc
okay so central means it's in the middle
and peripheral means it's off on the
side
okay so when you're thinking about this
and a network
peripherals mean stuff like what you
mentioned yesterday
stuff like printers um modems
file servers um as um you know
for hard drives that are associated with
those okay
so all of these are peripherals who can
access them
and who can do different things to them
okay so for instance
let's think about printers
okay um a good example often on a
network right
you may be able to access a printer but
what does accessing that printer
actually include well i assume that
means you can print to it
right fingers crossed otherwise your
access is not very useful
but there are other things you can do
with a printer okay for instance
there's not just printing but there's
also cancelling jobs
okay there's also the disabling of a
printer
so for instance if i'm the administrator
and i can see someone is you know
printing out hundreds of pages of color
things
and it was just by accident like someone
was impatient and they pressed okay like
50 times while they were waiting for it
right
because they just thought it was lag so
i want the ability
as the administrator to be able to shut
down the printer and stop everyone's
printing jobs from going
just like that okay but i don't want
everyone to have this kind of
access right because that would be um
rather chaotic right
where's my print job okay so you've got
you've got different levels of access
for different kinds of peripherals
printers is just one example what about
modems
what kinds of different things would you
expect to be able to do with a modem
uh you probably want to download stuff
off it
if you're going to want to download
stuff you want to be able to
tell the internet server you're
accessing what you want to download so
that implies you have to be able to
upload things
okay that seems pretty base level what
else might you
as someone who say is running the
network as the administrator
what power might what you want over the
modem
that you say don't want everyone else to
have any thoughts
ah changing things like say proxy
settings
you might want your modem to only access
the network through a particular proxy
which is exactly what the school does
we actually have access i think i think
tpg is who provides our internet
connection
okay but we have our modem set not to
direct to tpg servers all the time but
to go through
the department of education's proxy okay
what else
ah good so we don't just want people to
be able to download whatever they want
we want to say put some restrictions
bandwidth restrictions for instance
and with restrictions perhaps you don't
just want anyone walking along
to be able to access your network if
it's wireless right
so sorry your modem if it's wireless so
you might want to enforce things like
passwords
and you don't want just anyone to be
able to walk along and change the
password of your modem
okay so all of these are examples of
different kinds of
access levels you can assign to
different peripherals and then of this
list we could say
some people have access to this and to
this but not
to this or any kind of combination you
like
okay
so as for assigning rights this is for
the hardware side
okay